very good morning to you mr. Smith and
first of all what do you make and what
have you heard about from Seema Malhotra
about these these allegations of illegal
entry into her office well I don't know
anything about it do but I've seen the
stuff in the papers this morning I think
it's four seamer to talk about that I
think the key thing is look we need a
positive debate in the labour party now
about the future of our party that's why
I'm standing my grave worry is you will
know to him it is that the party might
split apart that having been a great
force for good in Britain for a hundred
years and more we could we could cease
to be that am I worried has been that we
are not looking at the moment like
government in Waiting we don't look like
a credible powerful opposition and one
that people can imagine running the
country and I think that's what we've
got to be because the Tories you know
with their austerity program be causing
damage in my constituencies and
constituencies like mine across Britain
and it's time for for labor to really
get up off its knees and start fighting
back against the Tories and I know
that's what Jeremy wants to but I'm not
sure he can do that and I'm saying to
Jeremy I think it is time for us to hand
the flag on to a new generation of labor
leaders to take that fight to the Tories
what would you know Jeremy wants that
you don't eeks capable of it but do you
believe that Jeremy Hannity John
McDonald who's been saying it again
today really want to stop the this
infighting the attacks that are going on
you're saying that many of them are
coming from the corbin side those
attacks and they're causing that that
feel about labor that it really isn't
fit to govern well I I hope they do both
want all of these things as I'm sure
they do look we all want the Labour
Party to be a powerful opposition to the
Tories we all want us to be a united
opposition but we haven't been in recent
months we've become more and more
divided more and more fractures some of
that is about concerns about Jeremy's
leadership and whether he's really a
leader of men and women he's a he's a
principled man and someone who's got
deep labour values but our question is
can II
take the Labour Party to where we need
to be which is in power because without
winning elections without labour being a
serious party of government again that
all the principles are just hot air if
we can't put them into practice through
winning power to exercise it on behalf
of people then what's the point of being
in this game but I mean just on that mr.
Smith would you like to see a more full
throated denunciation of some of the
abuse that's going on from jeremy corbyn
I would but I but I've said that before
doing it and I think you know time is
now Frank leaf in this leadership
contest for us to start talking about
what it is we want to do I'm very clear
we need a Labour Party that is saying to
the country would be float in the banks
and floating finance for a long time
here we need to start floating the
people I want to talk about my plan for
a British New Deal to spend 200 billion
pounds on New School's new hospitals fe
colleges skills sure start centres
that's the sort of language that labour
voters and labour members I think a
crying out for from a Labour government
and and we've not been with not being
good enough at sketching out what our
manifesto what our prospectus for
winning back Paris we weren't good
enough in the last period of opposition
we haven't been good enough recently
it's time for label to get back on the
front foot we've got a really you know
radical right-wing tory government here
they're hiding behind some of our
language but the truth is austerity cuts
and more cuts and now brexit leaving our
country in crisis we've never needed a
more powerful opposition and we've never
looked further from power all right well
let me ask you about brexit because you
want a second EU referendum and this is
about political will I mean it's only a
month ago when it was clear from the
United Kingdom that the people want to
leave the EU why do you want for that
well it was a very marginal decision and
I completely respect that people who
voted on either side of it did so in
good faith but I think a lot of people
now feel that they were fibbed to they
were lied to by some of the brexit tears
this 350 million quid a week we were
meant to get for the na
into immigration all of these things
were lies obviously and i think it is
now right for us to say the Labour Party
should be arguing for a proper debate a
proper negotiation a tough negotiation
on behalf of the British people to make
sure that we know exactly what the terms
of the deal will really be as opposed to
what was promised and at the end of that
we've got of the courage to save the
British people we trust you once more to
say is this what you wanted is this what
you imagined brexit was going to look
like for Britain or is it not and people
in this country I think will respect the
Labour government that says them we
trusted you last time but we will trust
you again in 18 months or two years time
either in a second referendum orator
another general election in which we are
arguing to stay in the European Union I
firmly believe we're better off in
Europe but I respect the views of those
who said no I also respect them to
rubber-stamp the deal when the moment
comes all right i mean there's another
question coming your way I suppose about
political will and it's within your own
party is so you will accept Jeremy
Corbyn won overwhelmingly last year when
he was elected leader of the Labour
Party in all the polling telling us now
he's gonna do it again why do you think
you can thwart that well because I think
I've got the ideas in the energy and I
think I've got something to say about
what the future of the Labour Party
looks like the truth is we've got
massive challenges in this country doom
of challenges our productivity
challenges of communities feeling that
they'll be going backwards for a long
time under successive governments and
labor when we are at our best we're
united and we're telling a hopeful story
about the country and I think we can do
that I know what we need we need
investment in this country we need a new
deal is going to pump billions of pounds
into communities you know the northern
powerhouse it's a great idea from the
Tories run at the moment that's all it
is let's make it a reality let's turn
our northern cities into real
powerhouses of our economy let's invest
in the bits of Britain that we keep
reading about that feel left behind
that's what labour can do and if I'm
given a chance to lead our party that is
what I will turn us into a party that is
gay
people a sense of Halep that is firing
their aspirations and ambitions I mean
but part so a big part of course of
Labor's revival has to be renewing its
appeal in Scotland after what happened
at the general election do you think
that can happen and let's just look at
your vote for trident again that the
Scottish people voted overwhelmingly for
the Scottish National Party in the
general election and it's explicit they
don't want Trident you do well I'm just
being honest with people do it about
that I'm someone who firmly believes we
want the world all of us in labor
without nuclear weapons I'm a
multilateral asst time I've ever night
on that and lots of other things we all
want to get rid of all of the bombs
across the world but I don't believe
that the way to do that is to
unilaterally get rid of ours first I
know the argument the argument is that
we would encourage others to do likewise
but I'm afraid I think that's a bit
naive and I'm afraid that securing the
defense of the realm securing the
security of the British people has to be
uppermost in our mind and the world to
me I don't know buddy you do it but
every day I pick up the newspapers it
looks more volatile more unpredictable
more dangerous so I don't think it's the
right moment for us to just get rid of
our defenses I think it's the time for
us to stand strong in the world to look
out to the rest of the world in to say
let's be in the vanguard if you like of
getting rid of nuclear weapons let's use
ours as a bargaining chip to get
everybody to start thinking once more
about how we collectively get rid of
nuclear weapons across the world that's
been Labour's policy more or less since
the 1950s and I think it should be our
policy going forward okay good to talk
to mr. Smith thank you very much she
becomes me thanks a lot